now though it's time for our first award
to present it I am so honored to welcome
one of the great actors of Our
Generation or any other he's a two-time
Tony winner a two-time Emmy winner and
an Academy Award winner please join me
in welcoming to the game awards Al
Pacino
so cool thank you
oh thank you thank you hello everyone
it's really good to see you here
uh this is uh an experience for me
uh what I didn't expect but here I am
as usual doing my surprising thing to
myself
but anyway
uh I I I may come as it may come as a
shock to you
but uh I I I I'm it's hard for me to see
the teleprompter
but anyway
uh but uh in the in truth
I don't play a whole lot of video games
but I do have however spent a lot of
time watching my kids play them
yeah
and I've continued to be thoroughly
impressed and uh
entertained by the uh unique and
immersive Ways video games
tell their stories
and especially
especially naturally
by the performers
who helped tell these stories uh because
as an actor I've learned that whether
you're on a stage or in front of a
camera
or inside an audio booth
always
fundamentally always we're the same
we we are all trying to tell a story
in our way
uh with our kind of Truth
and I am honored
to be here tonight
to celebrate the achievements
of these incredibly talented actors who
by breathing life into these stories
have helped elevate
the medium of video games to a new
height
foreign
the nominees for the best performance of
the year
oh best performance
I have to find a way to fix it all let
me answer so we're out in the Forbidden
West everything was so nice
quiet go to hell and still I fall off
and that's gonna have me do what's
necessary I don't find boys have much to
say for themselves
you don't scare me I can't talk about it
but you don't believe in any of it who's
keeping you safe
[Applause]
best performance
I'm working out now this is heavy
finally I didn't work out today so I'm
doing you don't mind do you if I do a
little league
the best performance
winner
Christopher Judge for God of War
thank you
[Applause]
[ __ ]
okay
now I see why I couldn't get more than a
plus one
um
thank you to the game awards
um
first of all uh
I have to thank my mama
um
who's
believed that I would amount to
something good would uh never waver even
though it looked like I'd never amount
to anything good
my brother
who's my hero
at 40.
changed his life
went to medical school and is now Dr
Judge
[Applause]
my children
[Applause]
who I am forever
proud of
forever thankful of and still the best
role I've ever had is being your dad
Sony Santa Monica
Miss Yumi yang
it is an honor and a pleasure
to work
for you and with you you are a unicorn
because you actually proved that for the
first time ever
the trickle-down Theory actually worked
Corey barlog thank you brother
thank you uh for
believing in me and thank you for having
me read for the role
um
I was the last actor in California to
read for it
um and Corey
said to me he didn't think I would do it
and uh if I had known it was a video
game back then I might not have
boy how things have changed
um
Matt
rich
Dory Bruno Erica bees oh everyone
who made that volume so special
and so sacred
uh everyone
at every level
be a designer be it whatever it was who
worked
under extraordinary conditions
to get this game out
[Applause]
Mr Eric Williams
I I think it's kind of common knowledge
that uh
we were honored to go to Tribeca after
2018.
and When Corey took me outside and said
he wouldn't be directing the next one I
literally did quit
I quit
and he said no
I vouch for Eric
and I said
Eric Williams better be a beast
Eric Williams is a [ __ ] Beast
[Applause]
I relate
to Corey on
kind of a artistic level a
level of of that side of me
Eric Williams and I
are from such the same place two
different parts of the country
two different upbringings
but two from a very similar
emotional place
and
I'll never forget
I guess I can't say what it was but it
was something
that moved me
so deeply and
there's a there's a time frame that
cinematics have to fit into
hopefully not speeches
um
and I I couldn't reel it in
and Eric came over to me
and he just hugged me and just held me
as I was sobbing
and then he said words I will never
forget
okay big guy now give us one we can use
to
this amazing wonderful
group of actors
um
who brought as much or more
than I did
every single day
I mean we were in there and The Bravery
of
this group of actors who share their
heartache their loves their lost loves
their loneliness
I am so grateful and thankful
that
I got to spend all those days in that
volume with you this is for all of us
Sonny
I wasn't lying I voted for you
your work was astounding
you're the future of this
just never
forget
the two things I hopefully gave you
hire me
don't be a douchebag
to every single person in this room no
matter what game it was you touched you
are heroes because you got so many
people in the world through a very
difficult dark time that's still not
over
[Applause]
games in the gaming community means so
much to this world to so much
in the course of dreams and escapism and
and just
being better
um thank you thank you to the rest of
the nominees
have a great night
and I met Al Pacino
[Music]
[Applause]